I want to I want to do Jiu-Jitsu again
but I don't want to take my earrings can
I tell you what happened when I did
Jiu-Jitsu it's like how sad it is I'm
like e did I tell you I got like
ringworm and like the half of my spa of
my space did I tell you I got ringworm
the half of my face right before New
Year's Eve and I spent I don't know what
year it was it was like the turn of like
2010 to 2011 with [__] like Harvey
Den just half ring what does it look
like what does ringing look like it's a
full circle worse than what it looks
like it's how it feels it's so [__]
itchy but it was so horrible that the
mats were so dirty that I got my whole
face was disgusting when I was little I
used to get um I got like a ring a red
ring in my armpits and they said it was
a yeast infection under my
arms when I was in kindergarten
kindergarten that seems a bit young to
get a yeast infection and my omits yeah
it wasn't even in my D who did that to
you yeah what the hell someone smearing
their dirty panties on your pits when
you're sleeping
maybe sounds like you were like in a
Filipino household cuz when Filipinos
they get well not anymore not Filipino
Americans but when girls would get their
periods they would like throw flowers on
you and then they would like make you
jump a couple steps it's this this whole
ritual but if you're a boy with get it
out you're just like plopping clumps but
if you're a boy with acne some Filipina
aunties will try to force their Period
Panties on your face really yeah to try
cuz they say like the period blood will
help with whatever the original vampire
facial yeah exactly at least it's a pad
not a tampon cuz that would be weird
just rolling a tampon but the tampon
more efficient pad kind of nice it's
like a dab it's like a I like the idea
can get SLA them across the
face hi you guys I miss you this week
I'm am I a pilgrim am I a witch burning
at the steak who who can say but next
week I am on tour I'm going to be in
Detroit oh my God uh October 19th and
then October 20th and 21st I'll be in
Chicago tickets are going fast for that
one Hometown shows I'm really excited
and then I will be in uh Boston November
thir fourth uh DC November 5th and San
Jose November 2nd and then Irvine later
in the month I can't wait to see you
guys you can get tickets at Esther on
i.com hi sluggy I hope you're enjoying
uh your lives and get ready for Steph
Tov this episode is going to be crazy I
love her so much um you can come see me
live doing standup comedy my favorite
thing to do in the entire world you can
see me um October 13th through 15th at
the La Hoya Comedy Store this weekend
it's going to be the best I was going to
be recording my special that got pushed
for production reasons but it's still
going to have the Vibes of a very
special weekend so come see me there I
also will be in San Jose California at
The Improv November 17th and 18th and
Houston Texas December 15th and 16th go
to Annie letter.com shows to check it
out and you can always see me on annwood
every Thursday love you guys choose the
mood that's right for you order your THC
gummies from mood today and for 20% off
your first order and free gummies go to
hello.com and use promo code trash
Tuesday that's
hell.com promo code trash Tuesday for
20% off your order and free gummies you
go to getquip.com tr Tuesday right now
you'll get 20% off any electric
toothbrush Mitten gum dispenser water
flosser that's your 20% off any electric
toothbrush mint and gum dispenser water
flosser at getquip.com TR Tuesday spell
GE tqi
p.com trash Tuesday quip the good habits
company wait Annie do you want to
introduce step oh this is exciting okay
this young man
um Steph and I are are competing for the
deepest voices in com in female comedy
uh this is Steph toaf she has a podcast
Steph infection which is that is such a
great name it's a good name I'm prettyy
pumped up with and she asked you about
infection like it does it goes there it
goes where you think it might yes it
does uh she's a paid regular at The
Comedy Store she's been on Netflix she's
gonna be in Esther's movie hey one of
the million one of the million Esther's
movie does that bother you that you
weren't in the movie I have not I'm not
sensing anything here it's not that I'm
bothered it's just it's just a wild when
you find out how many people and then so
we saw Esther earlier and Esther goes no
no no Steph like had to be in the it's
like no no no I'm not set the steps in
the movie it's just it's crazy that it's
it's it's a who's who's of everyone I've
ever
met it's a who's who I but I was telling
you I'm like the role I did was not you
like it was a crazy bartender it was but
like I'm gross you don't look gross
you're very attractive like I can play
as we started [__] each other right
now I start eating your [__] like over
here I mean like you you mean like you
on camera you look like a very feminine
I can play a disgusting Pig and people
like yeah that that woman's been doing
this for 45 years you sound but I sound
gross Pig yeah you're like yeah they're
like a pig sucking on a trough and I'm
like uh me please step what kind of
infections have you had oh a lot we
should name all of the infections we've
ever had this is a fun I know we did
kind of start with the armpit yeah yeah
yeah yeah so you had a yeast infection
in your armpit I had my first infection
not Road Rash I had I have ringworm
ringworm my first big infection um when
I lost my virginity my Heyman was so
[__] thick brag um but
try to get in there uh no my highman was
so thick it bled I had to go to the
emergency like I was bleeding like clots
like how old were you uh 19 I waited
till someone loved me um 19 like clots
like the size of both hands were falling
out of me are you sure that was yourman
would they don't have like fibroids or
well I might have fibroids who know for
that but they went in and the doctor was
they thought something was stuck inside
me the guy's dick was big though it was
a big dick that you lost your virginity
to a big dick yeah yeah it was like the
shap like football was like in then out
then in oh yeah it was scary it was no
it wasn't good it wasn't a good penis to
lose the virginity to you got to
graduate to that that can't be your
first you didn't Choose Wisely I don't
think well I must have to choose I
didn't see the dick I was 19 I was
waiting I was in college I'm not gonna
now I now I've seen enough that I can
choose no I have turned down a penis I
we were fully making out watching I
think the the movie was mud yeah one
with
Matthew and um we were making out I
fully intended on having sex I saw his
penis and then I was like uh with all
due respect like I don't know what to do
with that and then I was like bye like
too big or too small uh no it was just
hooked downwards okay I like
aidi um Aid is fine any other direction
I would have been fine with I just I was
like wow I've never seen that he was a
decathlete I was like that [__] will
tear me up so I'm like bye I like the
way you're so kind about it I excuse me
I I bowed yeah sorry pardon me I must
say I don't know what to do with that
tow she off that's such a I've had a lot
of dick fics recently and like they're
horrendous like one this guy has gout
for sure and it's like it looks it's the
gross in his penis something's going on
my yeah my most infamous dickpick was
this guy had placed his penis he was
sitting Indian
style and he had his feet were like heel
to heel were together like this and he
placed his penis on top of like the the
insides of his feet and it was just like
e I'm not even getting to the dick like
there's so much going on before the dick
wait he did this in front of you no no
he sent me the picture well this is okay
this is what I'm talking about here so
this man has G his hands have gelt for
sure it's horrendous I can see uric acid
from from a photo oh it's some know and
he's he [__] it's the whole thing is
he's [__] a pile of rocks there's a
lot going on in it that was an
unsolicited dick pick I got and it's
like really okay so let me break this
down wow okay the face attached to that
disc I would never want to know for the
starters he's uncut cut but he um
there's something going on with a for
skin it's not well kept it's it wasn't
well cut too it looked like he used like
gardening shears or you know those the
scissors we use when like when try to
get the
crinkle in school yeah yeah it's like
the crinkle scissors he got he got a he
got circumcised out of Michael's
Crow okay in the back corner number one
his hands are emitus for sure I don't
think it's gout as much as I think it's
really poor circulation or r no Dr k
definely a danger to like the pubes are
blonde but I feel like I'm seeing like
too much pink yeah but why is why is it
up against some rocks it's the rock the
problem is look like he peed on the
Rocks too there's a there's so much what
but what is going on but I don't know
what's going on I don't know this man
this man DZ me on Instagram that's an no
that's an Instagram that just got sent
to me he it looks like he [__] on some
hot rocks and he wants to show you that
and then he peed on them afterwards cuz
the J was probably too hot yeah the they
don't the tip is so horrendous it looks
like it's literally like inside out
that's why I feel like if you open up a
penis tip and just like peel it inside
out it's scary I want to put things in
it yeah you can put a lot of things in
it you can put a whole [__] couch
inside that thing it's disgusting
anyways that's disgusting Sor we I
haven't got I got one dickpick randomly
I haven't gotten them in so long well I
did a Thing Once where a guy I I had
publicly said I didn't want dick picks
and then a guy sent me a dick pic so I
screen grabbed it and I posted it onto
his Facebook wall that's so funny I said
you sent this to me I said I didn't want
this and then he started freaking out
he's like I'm a teacher I'm like you did
the thing sorry I'm sorry you started to
did I go anything that happens after the
thing I said I don't consent to is now
on you wow you and teachers man they
really come for you in ways you got a
thing Hot for Teacher over here you're
like H teacher's hot for me I can't help
it wait a second so what other
infections have you had sta I had
novarian cyst when I was uh in grade
eight Canadian sorry um thank you for
apolog I have I I get uh I have chronic
hives that they think are from the
vaccine so every single day I break out
and Hive sometimes so bad I have to go
to emergency cuz my throat closes um
what spont oh I'm allergic to the sun
yeah that's a new thing I I have I I'm
literally I Blister in the Sun like the
song like I have you can see my I have
scars all over my legs right now from um
was wding my sister's wedding I was the
maid of honor and I broke out in like
third degree burns like when I came back
from the hospital I came back to the the
trip I had to go to the hospital like I
was literally it's like everyone's party
on the beach and I'm lying in my bed in
the hotel just like balling my eyes I
had blisters like full it was psychotic
they fully scarred my legs it's called
polymorphic Sun eruption where my like
it's how did that happen just being in
the sun wait I saw but it never happened
before I would get little patches on my
skin but this was like I guess cuz the
Mexican sun was a bit hotter and I was
like in and out of the sea a bunch whoa
I'm getting cancelled I'm getting canel
Mexican
son read it Ste the whole face Mexicans
I'm like the Mexican son's hotter um
yeah no it was uh it was insane so
that's and I have this thing called um I
call it towed hands but my it's actually
happening right now you can see I have
like blisters all over my fingers again
that's from the Sun if I'm out too
long so I saw this made for TV what does
what does the Lord want for you the Lord
wants me to live in a well just crawl
down a deep dark well and stay down
there weird cuz you're not even that
fair no I'm not I and I used to be like
fully tanned as a I saw made for TV
movie when I was 9 years old that
scarred me and it was about a family who
had to wrap their kids up like every day
because they were allergic to the sun I
don't know what this movie was called
but I was still a kid in the Philippines
growing up and I was like oh [__] like
this is [__] up they would be
mummified every
day I don't know if that's in your fut
your sister doesn't have it no one else
does no one in my family has any of
these [__] problems it's like
psychotic I don't know what is going on
what happened to you when you're were
little I don't know something weird
something something weird happened
honestly I'm really upset I was a really
cute kid and I was actually upset that I
was never molested well we'll see
there's enough hallucinogens on
this I is there there's something you're
oppressing if your body is like
attacking you like this what's in there
I to know we got to dig it up we got to
BR bring your Shaman I something
horrendous happened to me what I a
lineup of Shaman and you get to pick
which Shaman I got a lot of Shaman okay
you have a lot of Shaman this is scaring
me now I never thought about this that's
why I have all these issues I just
thought I was sick mentally and
physically but you never had actual
staff no staff okay no shockingly not
yet yeah knock on one not yet U fingers
crossed no guess
are you friends with like nurses a lot
cuz you need to be yes I have a couple
friends oh I got a couple yeah I got a
crazy AIDS phobia that I need to deal
with wait I the movie kids ruined my
life okay so I think really shouldn't
have been called kids cuz I was a kid
when it came out like oh it's and you're
like no wait how old are you stuff 38
okay so PE girls our age that aids
phobia thing was is real they made it so
easy to get AIDS in that movie
everything like everything was like the
first time I ever I did this Blood
packed with a boy when I was like 14
where we pricked our finger and then we
did this and for the next six years of
my life I kept thinking like I hope like
I know I have a and you didn't want to
get tested cuz you're like I have it I'm
so sure I have it I don't want to get
tested I get tested every 3 months a I'm
like really crazy they know you oh yeah
HF at Western in Hollywood shout out to
my peeps up there I love that place oh
my God have you ever said that there's
one there's one woman and I'm like if I
get it and she gets gives me the results
I'll be happy cuz she's like okay let's
do the yes 1 2 3 I'm like woo I'm like
why am I excited for this right now like
she gets me all [__] up every time I'm
in there like she such if anyone has at
the end this no literally she's so fun I
feel like she has like morocca behind
and she place should be like that all
the time she's best yeah like are you do
you like the dentist I don't hate it the
dentist always got me cuz it was like
fun they did a good job oh I go one a m
k sent me to one and this guy is too
much he sent you he was like he sent me
he's go to this guy and the guy's like I
I think everyone thinks I'm funny I'm
like I don't want a funny dentist no I'm
do open mic in my mouth right now let's
get to the [__] thing and he's always
doing riffs with me and I'm like and
then they're always like you don't have
a sense of humor like comedians never
it's like no no no you're just not being
funny you're not funny at all then he's
like we should do content I'm like I'm
not doing Tik Tok videos let me tell you
my okay I met a chiropractor and I will
I'll let I'll I did meet him at a comedy
show so I knew he was he did comedy oh
but he I met him at Flappers and he like
had this technique for cluster headaches
which is a specific thing I have so
whenever I'm dying of cluster headaches
I go to him and he had to come to my
house once cuz I just was too sick so he
came to my house and he had like my
skull in his hands and he literally made
me watch his set I was holding a set up
I was like I are you insane while he had
my my life you were held hostage it was
so crazy that's that's that should be it
was wild
and it's good fny no notes no notes
perfect I think we should all take a a
twice a year field trip to Cutting Edge
testing is where all the porn girls get
tested and they sign you can sign your
name on on the wall I met a new porn
star there was a porn star in the front
row at The Comedy Store and and she dm'
me I'm so excited what she I love porn
stars at the shows they're so they're so
cute they're so PR pretty and nice yeah
yeah I think there's like a kindred
thing going on with comics and and por
right cuz I think we're all we're in a
very interesting business and we're all
we all could probably have ended up
being doing other thing depending on
some guy tagged me on Twitter yesterday
I thought it was like I'm so cocky I
thought it was like ber C being like who
should be on the next tour and someone
like step to for sure I was like and I
open it and it's like this guy at Johnny
Sins wants to do a live porn and this
guy tagged me and I'm like what are you
talking about you're tagging me to do a
live porn like what the [__] I was like
would you live not live what's your
price stuff if today someone was like 6
million for one 30 minute video
liberating kind of I think I would do it
but not have my face in it I feel like
even though I've resisted with your sun
blister this is [__] hot dude yeah
yeah see I'm [__] the FES on me no I
know it's I'm Kaka no it's been on us
the whole time but I'm a turd I'm a full
[__] turd NOA right now no [__]
speaking of turd should we show this
this is a good segue okay I'm sorry my
parents are in my parents are in South
Africa right now okay my dad just got my
dad just got on Instagram this is his
second real ever he's made okay how
old's your dad my Dad's 65 he's
literally obsessed with these reals he
he puts music he puts music on them he
just posts this real so we're not going
to be able to hear the music okay so
it's it's Foo Fighters but this is the
real he just posted let's get to the um
the second photo did you not see did you
not see that the second photo is
rhinoceros taking the biggest [__]
[__] in its life and I literally text a
family group through I'm like Dad are
you [__] crazy it's like can you just
PA it I caught it no I think he honestly
was just like I'm in nature look at that
[__] [__] also look how big a rhino
[__] is he's [__] on its own kid
that's the biggest [__] turd I've
ever seen in my entire life and so I
post on me and my sister are both like
what the [__] are we doing on here no
one 12 likes but you wrote
dad like Dad are you [__] crazy my S
just puts like the [__] Emoji I'm like
that's so [__] funny he is noed and
okay here's the thing too my dad's been
liking he likes all my stuff he's very
supportive but sometimes I'll post like
you know post a couple photos like the
third ones like a thirst trap and then
my sister's like Dad you have to stop
liking CU I don't think he knows how to
scroll but I'm like being like [__]
fall on my lips or something stupid my
dad's like my it's my girl I'm like can
you not like this for [__] sakes I
guess it's fine but that that turd is
that's I idea if he likes her live born
that'll be an issue that's an issue
that's an issue my mom over what size
would have been appropriate for you
coming out of a rhino's butt I feel like
that's appro kind look like a football
is that does that remind you of the it
reminds me that's that's my that's my
highman that was my highman that's
exactly what happened though that I just
didn't think they were that big I don't
know have you ever seen a deer [__] no
that threw me off it's all little tiny
Pebbles come at a time the pellets I had
no idea like that was crazy that I just
I don't know why I thought it'd be more
wet yeah deer deer is nice it's like a
cute little but when they [__] their
butt opens and all those come out at the
same time I thought it was one at a time
fruit very bizarre over my why am I
looking up so much animal [__] over your
dad did this to you [__] I'm sick over
the pandemic my mom like started making
videos for the family and she
accidentally made like the the scariest
video like it was supposed to be for the
nieces for the nieces and nephews and it
they were people left them screaming and
crying it's like the scariest thing she
it was like she took my dad they found
this tree housee in these Woods my
parents go on walks all the time they
found this treehouse in the woods and my
mom dressed up like a little girl like
she doesn't know that's so scary to have
a seven-year-old woman dressed up like a
little girl she had pigtails and like
like red cheeks and then my dad dressed
up like a ghost and it's just like a
little girl playing with her doll but
like a 70 2y oldold woman like and she
got like this really spooky um did your
dad film this they had it like set up
and my dad was the ghost that came by
like kidnapped her it's the [__]
scariest [__] and then at the end they
go it's us just kidding love you and
it's like that's also scary and it was
liter they accid made the scariest thing
in the entire world and then what's that
M Night Shyamalan movie where they go to
the wrong grandparents oh I don't know
that that has was it the water the no um
the visit or something like that that
has that same kind of to it but I don't
remember what happened they blend
together there's a lady in the water and
got's from Philly I get excited you see
some Philly stuff it's like okay I saw
the one where the um the one where where
they were in the cabin the recent one
them night tralon one I haven't seen
that one I don't see anything that's ins
did your mom edit the video or was she
Ed it she does she it's crazy my mom
just like when you see that stuff are
you like oh it makes sense that I am
their child I love everything my parents
do basically I love we we went home
recently or I went home recently and and
um my dad did I tell you I might have
said this on your podcast but we like
love to Bing e together and so my dad
picks me up from the airport and we go
like I'm like oh I've been fasting like
do really my dad's like oh yeah my your
mom and I have been like really good on
this diet it's 45 minute drive home we
get to 40 minutes and we look at each
other like Chinese food and we just turn
around and we just Gorge ourselves for
like a full week just Oreos just going
crazy and I it's my favorite thing I
know like when my parents are dead and
I'm binge eating I'm gonna feel like I'm
with them but it's fun it's like I like
iing the G's gonna be bad for you oh my
God you're going to be a different
person I will be obes yeah you won't be
I want to turn my dad's ashes into like
you can make like brown Jewels yeah you
can I want to make a jewel or you can
like shoot people up in a balloon and
the balloon explodes and then they're
like in the atmosphere that's kind of
fun someone said you could do um tattoo
with like the ashes in like the that
seems a bit much well I want mine a
little bit more I want I I know it's a
health hazard and the City of La will
never allow it but I want to be tnted
like I Want My Dead Body attached to
like a bundle of dynamite and then blown
up like old school Chun chunks me on
like a railroad too like it's got to be
classic to traumatize like the general
public like that to me sounds fun wait I
know two separate people whose parents
have died by getting hit by a train why
how is it why is is it common to get
killed by a by accident or a suicide I
think maybe they were suicides and
that'ss but isn't that weird I was
thinking that the other day you it's
like my mom has been on the train three
times and she's gotten two of those
times someone showed her their dick it's
like certain things a normal train or
like a she was like on the subway okay
yeah that showed them her show she got
penises flash twice that's common I when
I first came to America like my first
week someone had their at the m in the
MTA BS had their dick in a Bible looking
at me and jerking off like right in
front but he's with the Lord so that's
okay he's accepted he got permission
Yeah Yeah from the man yeah yeah yeah he
everything was good did you guys ever
roll the joint with a Bible paper no how
do you you just take a piece of Bible
paper and you roll is Bible paper
special zigzags are 99 Cents but we were
children I don't know it felt cool to be
like we're smoking the Bible anyone in
this room do
that yeah you did hell yeah [__] yes
never in my life heard of this no this
seems like a I was like we're so cool
did you guys go through like a Satan
phase um Satan phase I was a I was a
hardcore Punker in high school I had the
dog collar on oh my God it was I wor the
dog collar for way I saw a dog collar
today from one of our themed episodes
and I was like should I just start
wearing this yeah just say nothing you
know what speaking of dog collar all of
a sudden I'm in a [__] spike dog
colge wait I took a BDSM test have you
guys ever heard of this
no and I want to a test yeah it's like
this whole thing it's actually not as
short of a test as I thought it was but
here's my summary um they ask a whole
lot of question but it turns out I'm a
switch hitter you guys I'm neither a a a
Dom or a sub you're a people pleaser
depending on my mood I switch around I
feel like I would be a switch too cuz I
don't I would I would I have a a vision
of a future pegging of Todd like he
keeps like I don't want that I'm like
there there's going to be a time I I
Envision like sitting at a table and
he's like okay so here it is like I am I
am a switch hitter I am a Voyer not an
exhibitionist because I don't like being
watched I want to watch other people
have sex um what is it the third one is
I am non
monogamous well I well yeah I've been
with two guys at one time um that's 92%
and I'm experimental a rape bunny but
I'm 67% vanilla so sometimes I just like
Christian sex of course course I don't I
I enjoy Christian sex anal right yes
anal no l balling my eyes out no I like
I enjoy just kind of lying there
sometime and I'm I'm smoking a joint out
of a Bible paper just watching it happen
I think people think that because we're
so aggressive on stage that we want to
be like that in the bedroom and I'm like
I'm pretty like I'm not doing a lot of
sexy talk I'm like I'm a mute I've been
yelling all night what you want me to do
my I like you want me to be quiet have
sex with me you like watching other
people have sex I feel like I'd be I'd
be having a laugh I I'd be something
would go off and I'd be like I well they
probably like comenting or you no no no
just like well would you compared
compared to being watched so I'd rather
watch than be watched because if I'm
being watched I can I can never come I
think I would rather relaxed enough but
also I do like the idea of like hooking
up next like side by side I love a I
like a hotel room bang I saw myself
[__] my ex-boyfriend me and I almost
committed suicide yeah I've never I've
Never filmed I was like oh there's two
[__] wild hogs in the room and I
didn't know that two [__] pigs got in
here it was that's my parents made a sex
tape when I was when we were like kids
we didn't see it what yeah no my parents
made a sex tape and they said that it um
that they I used to I forgot I have a
joke about that I'm glad I remember but
um they said that they just after they
watched it they just took a hammer to it
they were like it was two pigs like they
were like it was literally like monsters
[__] each other it's Mir is in a
hotel room unless you're like I I want I
want pitch black when I have sex my mind
I'm way hotter than what I am so what
I'm thinking I look like is going to
look a lot better I've never I'm not
like a home video [__] there's no [__]
are you I've never done it I I think I
have such a poor perception of myself in
real time you're the opposite you look
better when I look back at Old
photographs or videos of myself even
[__] I'm like I'm a [__] goddess
what the [__] was I thinking in that
moment being insecure I mean you know
for my spank bank you guys don't have
spank Banks I don't really I'm I'm not
involved in my Spang bang I don't no no
no I don't want my spangang is not I'm
not in it that [__] staying in here and
the men that have slopped on it we're
keeping that we talk same thing I'm like
I've asked this question before I've
only taken nudes I'd be happy where you
saw I posted you other day
but no but you were I was covering it
were you saw Steph's [__] yeah but she
was like oh I was I was you know I got a
big hand I I was hiding a lot of it you
know it was it wasn't like there it is
it was a lot of it tued up tued around
talk you got yeah you got I'm good at
talking but Duck game going a rolling
it's like a really tightly rolled
burrito in there everything's in there
you're not going to see it you got it
open um but then you can't walk too much
you got real slow real I can't uncross
my legs we are we aren't moving the
whole podcast Steph if you were dating
someone seriously and you find out that
they still have um videos and nudes of
their excess in their hidden folder um
without that um I freak the [__] out
would you yeah my ex was following so
many of his exes all of his exes on
Instagram and still looking at them and
commenting and liking and I I it really
[__] me up when I I was dating a guy
who was in full contact with every ex
and would send them I love you all the
time fuut to like five different girls
and I was just like g whatever why I
don't know I just was like so it's the
so no so no exes in the spank bank I
mean I think you just have it mentally
but if he had like a folder that they I
knew they were looking at I was like why
wouldn't like I would be like I'm not
enough right now we've been through this
we've been through this before but Todd
does have one but it's like he can't
delete it and I thought he was lying but
he literally can't it's like it's like
in his cloud or on another phone or
something it it sounds like he's lying
but no I have a video on my phone that I
can't get rid of so weird like I don't
want this I don't want it's like my
friend set from 5 years he's Bing his
dick off I don't want the [__] set on
here I I can't get it off New York Comic
Club every day I delete it and it won't
go away I don't know what this is
[__] Alex theone bombing 5 years ago
like I need this off oh my he's going
buddy hey buddy and I'm like why do I
[__] have this not using the mic a
get off the stage
Canadian he's hilarious but the video is
bad do you see in my BDSM results 0% the
greater 0% daddy mommy 0% age I don't
like daddy mommy my okay my ex-boyfriend
came into like he was pretty fresh off
like a long relationship he tried to
bring his [__] from his last
relationship into me and it was so
upsetting to me it was a lot of like
sibling [__] Oh Daddy stuff and and
calling me like a stupid [__] and I was
like so he was into degrading degrading
I'm not I think she was before no I
don't degrading I was like the minute I
was like get off me I'm already
degrading when I look in the mirror I'm
like you disgusting [__] I you need
to like worship yes you insane yeah I'm
not into degrading at all but um the
daddy mommy stuff is a little bit
strange like the most I'll the farthest
I'll take it is if I do roleplay it's
always my dad's best friend or his like
hot coworker or something like that but
never daddy I've never done role play
ever I I feel like you'd be so good at
it I know but I feel like I immediately
want to play the man I have I come out
like a mustache and a w what are you
doing wait no you don't have to dress up
you can in my hand I'm Coming Out full
mustach have dreams where you're a dude
do you have dreams where you're a dude
and you're [__] a girl no I have
those and I'm crushing I'm like oh my
God I would be the best guy i' a good
lesbian I feel like I just I needed to I
keep trying but you so what's the issue
you have the voice you have the look I
know you have the wolf cut i' I've you
have the hair even the socks are kind of
gay I know there're like golden
retrievers um I I don't know I I've
tried so many times even a golden
retriever is kind of a gay choice I
drive a [__] Subaru Outback I'm a
dyke I swear to God de down I don't know
what the problem because I feel very
similar to you like I do feel like I
have like a like there is a lesbian
inside me but it just isn't it never
comes to same but I think that the term
for that Crush
heteroflexible where it's like yes you
lean more towards you know being
straight but that when I hooked up with
the girl how do you feel when cuz you
have hooked up with girls before yes how
do you feel good and I always one-onone
or in the context of a three one-onone
and and like I think with me it's a very
specific woman so like if like with guys
I'm like a pig I'm like [__] him [__]
him [__] him with wom it's like
literally I'm like a construction worker
I swear to God I'm such
what's your what's your I super F and
the ones that like me are super Butch
I'm like we can't be two men in the room
it's too much I can't be I can't look at
me I need somebody like you I like I met
this girl years ago in Amsterdam if
she's watching this I hope you I don't
know her name I was with my boyfriend
that broke my highman and we're walking
across this bridge and she's like
beautiful blonde ruined it with 14 night
pads anyways beautiful blonde like woman
and she like stopped me and she's like
oh my God your voice and I was like what
she's like I love your voice and she was
like Curly like Marilyn Mon Rob maybe
this was I made this up I was so high am
but I swear to God this is a real person
and she's like you should come back with
me and I was like like my boyfriend it
she was on it was crazy it was insane
and I was like that that woman I was
like that was like the woman of my
dreams I'm like I don't know and I have
been like I've had like I had another
girlfriend my first girlfriend I was 24
we ated for like three and a half months
and it was it came on really strong I
just broke up with himman man and it was
like I went from him seven years to I
was like it was like a lot and it was
like she I really liked her but I think
she was like shaved head kind of it was
I think I just want like a you wer it
wasn't like yeah but I like I like
around with women like I'm not like I'm
not like disgusted to eat puss I'm down
there oh you you're not you're into
eating puss but also like doct Drew
called me out on this he was like eating
[__] or not wanting to eat [__] does
not determine your sexuality like at all
there are many men straight men out
there who don't necessarily love eating
[__] either shut up and get down there
I'm sick of that like we going to suck
your dick get the [__] down there I know
that is you have
to my teeth idiot it's not an option
think last night I H many pews in my
mouth I'm like what is this it's
disgusting I know it's so annoying
handle yourself so you don't like hair
on the shaft or or anywhere else like
like still attached to the body in my
throat I don't want it to be fully
shaved either fully shaved and shiny is
like unacceptable to me no I don't
that's creepy it's disgusting bald down
there is weird I hate bald down there
well they're trying to get as many Tom
Sandal from um Vander pump is fully
shaved like that is what that reminds me
of like a Tom sandal like GH wait not
sand is sandal the one that cheated or
the other one sandal is the one that
probably has is he the one that cheated
okay yeah yeah yeah no it's like no it's
also like I'm hairy as hell I'm not I'm
like it's going to be weird I'm not
getting rid of the hair the hair is
we're hairy that's I I've accepted I
have a hairy ass have you ever dat a
like a fem guy yeah did that work was
there any no again I feel too masculine
yeah I don't want to feel like I feel
like I don't know yeah but that's weird
because you like super fem girls I know
it's very bizarre CU in that scenario
you would be the guy yes it's like it's
cut and dry and I think yeah a man I'm
like I don't want to be the man with a
man like I want to be the man with you
don't want to be like yeah and I've been
the man bumping chest with them
wrestling them get over here you son of
a [__] taking him down let's go [__]
throw the pig skin around he's like can
we just watch a movie I'm like let's
[__] wrestle I'm similar in that like
I almost need a girl with my exact
stature she has to be my height she
cannot be shorter cuz I don't again I
don't want to feel like the dude like it
has to be someone maybe sporty more
athletic little titties I the only girl
that I looked up with was like and it
was like we were friends for a while but
it was like you know sort of romantic or
whatever and she looked so much like a
boy and it was just so weird and then
when we did finally hook up and she
wasn't a boy it was like almost like a
betrayal I don't know it was like so
soft soft I was like a I like the soft
kisses sometimes but then sometimes I
want to be like [__]
yeah you're a switch hitter yeah I'm a
switch hitter I got to do this [__]
test and see what the hell so weird
though but I've never like I've never
been with like a super pretty fem girl
and been like like leaning like it's
never been like all of a sudden we're
like you know I've spent this whole
summer trying right like I've gone out
on more dates with girls than I have
with boys because I'm like I'm just
going to power through like I there's
this idea in my head where I'm like have
I just been programmed to just want I
know so I'm like so I I watch fully
lesbian porn only in fact I would I
can't remember a time when when I've
watched porn with a dick involved so I'm
turned on by it but when it comes down
to it I just there isn't like a natural
like pull and the I made out with a girl
at a bar at The
Rustic you again yeah I have made out
with so many people at the r again oh my
God all I'm doing is eating [__] 2
lbs of myself you guys crazy it's so
dark in there it's the best place to
make out cuz i' made wings too I made
out with the ugliest people in there and
I'm so proud of to say did I ever tell
you the story about when I woke up this
is obviously before I quit drinking my
friends had moved to a place that was
like right next to the Y old rustic and
I was still living in Santa Fe and I
came of course it was my my friend was
moving out to eventually marry my
ex-boyfriend who I was still in love
with so of course I was like oh drive
out I like you over like crying um
sure yeah I'll be in the
wedding blood no yeah no I know you're
using me because you know that I love
him still and it makes him hotter for
you um but so I get wasted with all of
them we go to Y rustic and I bring back
like the big sign that's like two for
one like Budweisers or whatever I steal
the sign I drag it back to their house
I'm like isn't this awesome why is this
a thing we did why was like you are
disgusting you're a disgrace how could
you do this nobody thought it was cool
in my head I'm like I'm still high
school like I'm hilarious I
[__] then I had to drag it back they
made you take it back they made take I
would have hyped you up I I stole
signage from everywhere if I could have
ripped stop signs off the road there
nothing cooler than stop signs and like
I take the subway sign off the Toronto
TTC it was the best the long ones all
the stops oh my God love yes we're like
this is [__] so cool I had the worst
date of my life at e Rin I brought this
guy I hope you're listening you [__]
piece of [__] he talked about himself
the whole time like I swear I swear to
God at one point I started going yeah
and just making weird sounds just to see
what he would do and he didn't even he
just kept going through he's like wake
up at 6:00 I go to the climbing gym then
by 7 I'm at the office and I was like is
this guy [__] crazy so I biked there
by the way you can't be single on a r
climber no he's a [__] relationship
he's also one foot tall shut up so I had
I I biked there so I went to go see I'll
walk you your bike I'm like okay I'm I'm
a loser wear a helmet I'm safe so I
wouldn't put my helmet on and when I
like I clicked it up he like came he
like leaned in and I was like oh okay so
I leaned in for the K he goes whoa whoa
and I'm like excuse me you dead he's
like uh no and like turned and ran down
the street and I was like I will run you
over with my [__] bike right now I
will [__] take my two- wheeler bike
my bicycle I was so pissed I hate that
guy when it comes to cannabis you want a
product that strikes just the right mood
and mood ships you affordable 100%
federally legal Delta 8 and Delta 9 THC
products with specialty strains that can
make you feel mellowed out productive
creative even euphoric and social mood
puts an end to guessing games with
federally legal forms of THC extracted
from hemp plants all of their products
are regularly thirdparty tested in DEA
registered Labs sourced from small
family farms and grown organically and
there's something for every mood the
experts at move the experts at mood have
tested and tailored different strains
for specific moods so you can do
euphoric social and erotic you can
connect with other people around you you
can be energized creative and focused
and seize the day and be productive you
can be chill sleepy they have a body
Soother to help you relax and unwind and
they have great tasting gummies classic
flow convenient pre-rolls and so much
more for me like if I am going to use
THC it's going to be very specific and
tailored I don't want just a random
experience I want to know okay right now
I'm in the mood to feel creative I'm in
the mood to just feel mellow and relaxed
and that's why mood has been such a huge
part of my THC life choose the mood
that's right for you order your THC
products from mood today and for 20% off
your first order and free gummies go to
hood.com use promo code trash Tuesday
that's hello o o.com promo code trash
Tuesday for 20% off your order and free
gummies you guys know I've never had a
cavity in my life what never and I want
to just keep this going forever you
never had a cavity I've never had a
cavity I don't intend on ever getting
one and quip is my new best friend you
don't get them from sucking on bananas
nope quip is my new favorite it's
literally they make it's like the apple
of Dental products the toothbrush is so
sleek and cute like I'm sorry but if
you're going to be on the go or on a
group trip you're all renting a house
and Palm Springs bust out your quip at
night youp you'll be the sleekest
chicest girl there they had the timed
Sonic vibrations with 30second pulses to
guide a dentist recommended two minute
clean cuz like I don't want to have to
think I I've been brushing long enough
it literally tells you how long you've
been doing it and the pressure is good
too so you don't like overbrush
overbrush your gums also EST when she
said she had no cavities you were kind
of quiet I was quiet and we'll just
leave it at that and also now you can
skip the batteries and snap into healthy
habits with the new rechargeable
electric toothbrush all the features of
the original clip plus one magnetic
charge charger that powers up to 3
months of brushing and I've recently
just gotten into water flossing but you
guys this is it it's crazy look at this
it's so fun it's so effective oh my God
oh my God I didn't I didn't that was
100% an accident I told you it's very
strong and
violent it hits all the right spots with
gentle or deep clean pressure at the
touch of a button and the extra wide lid
the lit that no don't hold the button
down too long cuz it will just keep
going I'm just going to tell you that or
if I don't know what you're up to with
this but my mouth has literally not
never been clean until I got this water
flosser I know and you just got it
unfortunately and they also have have
you seen the gum and mint dispenser it's
so it's so
cute where it go here it is oh and the
gum prevents cavities so and freshens
breath when chewed for 20 minutes after
eating oh and it's sugar-free and has
tooth friendly Xylitol with zero
calories it's long lasting mint flavor
crunchy crunchy oh crunchy yeah it is
long lasting mint flavor crunchy try
layer design I'm sorry but it like you
know how in middle school when you
pulled gum out of your bag you're like
the most popular kid there imagine doing
it with this like imagine being at a bar
and you pull this out and people think
you're a drug addict and you're like no
this is just gum it's because I'm
healthy it also kind of looks like mace
so you can be like stay away from
me if you go to getquip.com trash
Tuesday right now you'll get 20% off any
Electric toothbrush mint and gum
dispenser water flosser that's 20% off
any electric toothbrush mint and gum
dispenser water flosser at get quip.com
Tuesday spell
gq.com
Tuesday quip the good habits company and
hopefully Annie didn't ruin our camera
system with the dental water flosser and
if I did who cares I have a cute
toothbrush grow
up I've G okay oh this what I want to
bring up this is what I want to bring up
I I want some opinions here I want
everyone's opinion on this so what's
going on isting I feel like my comedy is
so aggressive that it's hard men never
hit on me after my shows and if they do
they're terrifying so it's like I feel
like I've been trying to like find a
middle ground of like the guys on the
apps when they find out a comedian
they're like weirded out by it and if
they see my set they hate it so my guys
that already know who I am are I'm like
maybe you guys are kind of fans of me so
this guy I'm not going to say his name
has been following me on Instagram for a
long time DMs I click on this picture
very attractive okay very attractive
younger 27 lives in Laguna Beach I'm
like okay so I'm like here's my phone
number let's text we start texting like
crazy okay texting like crazy got to
open this up we make plans last Monday
okay so we're texting I'm talking like
there's a lot of text a lot of lot of
text you're being hilarious being funny
he's being funny he's being cute
whatever soing we're vibing so last
Thursday we make we made discussing how
we're going to go Monday night so Monday
night I'm like I'll be fre on six he's
like great
Thursday we're such psychers that we
have to have dates on Mondays by the way
L only and I made it very clear M the
night off but we had been talking he
like okay great we'll figure out a plan
we keep talking talk talking okay so
this is like Thursday he uh he asked me
a question about The Comedy Store I I
reply back him here nothing okay that's
Thursday Friday you're so funny oh yeah
yeah it's Thursday Friday Saturday
Sunday nothing and I'm like okay we have
plans for Monday so on Sunday I send the
eyeballs oh eyeballs is just the
eyeballs just the two balls go on what's
up the two balls is being like you can't
make PL you know what we should have you
know what there should be Emoji it
should there should be an emoji of Sonic
when he was tapping his foot oh my God
yes that should be the one like come on
like like so it's like okay we made
plans but I'm like I I it's weird to
make plans with somebody and then just
not talk so I'm like what's going on
Monday six 5:59 p.m. when we're supposed
to meet okay this is this is the text I
get I want everyone's opinion on this
good after afternoon SLG good evening
Stephanie no one's called me Stephanie
in my life creepy as hell I need to
apologize being Mia and for the lack of
communication I had taken my car into
the shop Friday to get some work done
and accidentally dropped my phone in the
endless Valley between the seat and the
center
console I'm sorry you're telling me a
27-year-old man left his cell phone in
his car all weekend long and at no point
went to check on it didn't buy a new
phone i' immediately buy a new phone
that's crazy find my phone find yeah so
the good news is I have both my phone
and my car back but I feel terrible for
leaving you hanging I know it's last
minute and it'll be later than attended
but if you still want to hang I'll head
your
way this is the biggest [__] lie
everyone's heard their entire life
correct there's no [__] way this is
real that's not real you think it's real
we have what do we have here no I want
no come here come here I need to hear
this wait hold on get on the mic okay
have you been ghosted have you been
stood up have you been stood up before
you ghosted are you single yeah okay I
want to hear this I want to hear your
opinion cuz everyone else is saying this
is a lie correct
[Music]
um what do you know this man I'm kidding
I don't know this this is actually my
boyfriend I just think I'm really
gullible what into the
mic I don't know this man I don't know
this man okay um I think I'm really
gullible and I just it's just something
I want to believe like why couldn't it
happen but I'm also am I just naive I
don't know but I just don't understand
the point of not responding and then
responding and then still wanting to
hang out and not setting the plan like I
just don't understand why the type of
ghosting to me is weird it just doesn't
make sense it doesn't make sense and I
just I I just picture all of us in here
are obsessed with our [__] phones
there's no [__] way how many days was
it that he was supposedly lost his phone
four days but the phone was was in the
car that was at the mechanic I could
believe so it's like the phone was in
the car that was at the shop where how
did the mechanic contact him how did he
get home from the mechanic if he
couldn't get an Uber with his but he's a
guy like they're they don't know what
they're doing the texts are blue so he
has an iPhone which means he he's on his
laptop he's on his laptop MacBook but
why am I making EXC they can always talk
to they why am I making excuses for the
stranger okay
my boyfriend who happened to marry my
friend who I moved out to Los Angeles
and I stole the sign he when he was
trying to break up with me so we we dat
I was like only 19 but he was like come
to Tennessee meet my parents with my
college boyfriend he's like I want you
have to meet my family I'm like finally
in love I finally found this funny
awesome guy right he's like you got to
come to Tennessee like get your ticket
like come for New Year's right so
Christmas he's he drops me off of the
airport I fly home he does not talk to
me the entire time my m so we have this
plan I have a ticket everything I'm like
okay I need to figure out like when I'm
going so I'm like I'm calling him I'm
emailing him all this stuff no response
finally he calls me Christmas eve and
he's like oh I forgot my phone charger
no okay it's like you can get contact
people I no that's crazy but you can get
contact with people all what I'm saying
like there's never like he has your
Instagram my Instagram exactly that's
that was what I was going to say next so
when um Bobby's been on the he's lost
his phone or whatever would lose his all
the time a million times but I know that
if I can't get a hold of someone through
my phone there's five other ways I can
do that and you don't want someone like
to leave someone hanging if you like
them and you said that like he said he
was a Phan of M he saw for a long time
he couldn't believe we were in talking
so all this stuff made me believe and I
was like and he was super cute and he's
being really nice and he wasn't being
creepy there was that's why I was like
trying to get comedy no he's he has
nothing to do with comedy he's like into
surf stuff and I was like this is this
would be perfect he lives kind of far
but not too close I just like all of it
here's the problem the thing is he does
want to hang out in the end so I don't
understand what the [__] point of all
this I just I really do not trust men my
ex [__] me badly and I'm like now I'm
like my trust has been sucked out of my
ass and now I'm like I'm like how do I
trust this man you don't trust man you
don't trust men you trust you find a man
who who does things that show you to
trust him I I would have yelled at this
I needed that what yeah like if I I'm
sorry Steph this guy is a is a no for me
okay this is what I'm like cuz I'm like
yeah no I'm like this is I didn't I
didn't maybe they maybe the younger
girls know what's
up texting and then it all of a sudden
doesn't work out I'm over that that's
like okay what would you what would you
reply to this then I would not reply
yeah I mean I believe it but I wouldn't
go out with him because I'm like I
believe you because you're a dumb man
okay you believe CU he's dumb but that's
it okay no okay so you POs to not have
your phone for 4 days it's actually not
humanly possible I didn't think it was
possible homeless people have phones and
they're charging them up and yeah it's
like this is not he maybe what does he
have a girlfriend or something that's
why I was like could be girlfriend could
be there there's so many other options
here and I was like I just I'm like I'm
not but it's like one thing if he's like
if he decides he doesn't want to like if
he was like flirting with you but he's
like in a relationship and he's like oh
I don't actually want to hang out oh
[__] this got real then there wouldn't
be the Stephanie text yes followup and
then I'll come hang out have you
facetimed him yet no no FaceTime has he
sent any photos of him like jerking off
now like have you like could this be
someone who's is it Jess no I have I
have his Instagram can we call him let's
see him no no I don't want to call him
let's see him let's call him no I don't
want to call him he's nothing he's gone
no he cuz I also want to give this
attention I don't want to give like
that's you know we're giving him like
full attention I mean I you're blushing
but it is peach colored like this I'm
blushing so I'm like I just also yeah I
don't want to give these can I see what
he looks like yes I'll see his because
this could change this could change a
lot cuz here's the thing he's not
there's just no way I think he's very
attractive as the isue very cute these
girls haven't been [__] over he's
still following me that's the thing if
you guys yeah I've been [__] over so
many times now I and it's just like
especially in this [__] this is the
least trustworthy looking human I've
ever seen I
hate that's so funny he's cute but I
it's like it was an odd telling it was
like
okay I see hold he's very cute problem
he's very cute that's the issue he's
very cute and again of you can get this
guy that's not this guy I mean he's so
stupid there was a guy oh my god there
was a guy I I there's there are these
guys that hover around comedy okay that
are like this there was a guy that I met
who was like a doctor like we were
vibing he came to The Comedy Store he
was like a friend of someone give me
your runoffs what what's going on here
give me give me these doctors no listen
we were vibing we were vibing so hard
like it was a Vibe Vibe and this was
when I had been like only dating shitty
comics and stuff and I was like I'm
ready to date someone with a real job
then I meet this like relatively
good-looking a little bit nerdy like I'm
still cooler than him um guy they're
always Rock there's always like a rock
climbing coming around I really love
that you don't follow him back I'm never
going to follow him back insane but so
okay wait so we're vibing everything's
kind of like crazy I say to his friend I
go I vibed with your friend and he goes
he's like yeah he's like I'm I don't
like setting people up because then I
feel and I go okay you don't have to
it's just like he's like a [__]
doctor and we've I mean there was an
obvious like we were flirting the whole
time like he even had like I looked at
his Instagram and he had like ugly
sandals you know when you're like I
guess I'll Overlook ugly sandals I'll
I'll Overlook no like leather
to and
um that it's green too I like the hard
banana no honestly I like a hard banana
I can't do a bruis one I throw up don't
throw you have I have a gang problem but
with specific things but anyway so
anyway so then he's like his friend goes
he's on a camping trip without his
phone I he's not going to be back for
two weeks I go abort abort
Mission I want nothing to do with them
it's like he sometimes he goes Mia okay
no I'm done I anyone that doesn't have
their phone for 4 days or doesn't have
I'm not interested in that mm-m I like a
back a lot of texting especially at the
top you get to know each other I like to
FaceTime a guy Eric Andre said I heard
him say that he only facetimes people
now before me we're busy MH you get
there today some guy [__] and we
mashed on Bumble and then he was like
I've dm' you before on Instagram I'm
like what so he like goes He DMS me and
then I made a joke he say a dad bot I'm
like oh how how big is his dad bot and
he's like well 53 I'm like 53 I'm like
your Bumble says you're 6 feet tall I
swiped right cuz you were 6 feet tall
look at your 53 dating a 53 no offense
by the way short Kings just be short be
short why you lying don't lie now you've
lied six feet at least say five six wait
short kings are apparently going out
together and having short King parties
you looking at me they stand on top of
each other shoulders jul yeah yeah we
don't no one know women Sees at the bar
like who's here but apparently they are
happen I was vibing with a guy and he
popped off the I was a bartender he
popped off the chair and I was I you
could barely see the top of his head
it was one of the most unbelievable
things like there was this one bartender
that I used to um go in and flirt with
and um my joke with my friend was always
that he was just going to wheel out one
day because I never saw the bottom of
his
body wait see this is where I think
dating has gotten a little bit [__]
for us and I miss the days or growing up
in the Philippines like there's there's
levels to the game first you have to ask
a girl if if you're allowed to court her
so even before you start shooting your
shot you have to ask to shoot your shot
so there is pre- courtship and then
courtship and then you go into a mutual
understanding and you have one more step
before you're official there's five
steps to it and I think we've just
bypassed everything straight into
situationships with no answers and no
like ending I like that my grandparents
were in arranged marriage I'm thinking
that I got maybe I'll just do that [__]
it wait maybe that's it I'm going back
to we should get you on um mered for yes
God yes I tried to get on love as blind
I tried real hard but I was like I know
right away I'd be like hey what's up
they'd be like Oh I'm in the wrong room
sorry Chad I'm like no no it's not it's
Stephanie no come on and I wanted I was
trying so hard I was like didn't
happen um Mar is so good because is
professional the darkest it's like may
as well be like True Crime it's so any
I've never watched it do people ever
last from it or no yes every once in a
while they do but God damn is it they
these matchmakers Miss so hard on one
you're like these people are repulsed by
each other they hate each think getting
one out here I'm not even kidding cuz
I'm having such a hard time meeting men
if I go anywhere else I meet guys the
second I leave the city with this city
it's like I don't know I'm [__] dying
no you just have to meet someone that
likes that you're a crazy intense [__]
yeah that's you have to a crazy mother a
crazy mother that's what that's what I
need you need someone with a crazy mom
that is the only thing that has ever
worked for me they are repulsed by what
we are a lot of men yes they don't like
what we are no kidding they can't stand
it and especially when you're vibing and
you're like oh these texts I'm [__]
being hilarious and they're probably
like yeah they're like please stop yeah
but I know them a lot I know I know what
I'm giving off it's a lot it's not a lot
I'm a nice person I'm very generous I'm
caring I act like a ghoul on stage but
I'm not I can I can be sweet I can be
nice yeah I think that I I don't think
think you're a lot or too much for
anyone I just think that have you seen
my set I was like have you seen on stage
cuz like
I no but there is someone who probably
loves that intense energy like we had um
dumbfounded on and he he um he talked
about just always wanting super strong
successful women I love when guys say
that and he means it and he's really
kind of walk that walk because he's
always been with smart strong successful
women I feel like it's just hard to find
those guys I know they're out there but
it's like where are they not on the apps
I don't know what the hell I try to be
people in public but it's younger you
got to always go younger too the ones
are crazy I'll go out the wild stuff I
think we can go hunting together I want
to go with you guys can I go with you
yeah I feel like she is a great great
wing woman we just be so loud like we'll
just get rid of the people that don't
want the yeah yeah I don't know yield
rustic yeah let's do that on like a
weekend you is that what it is okay yeah
it's hard like being a comic and dating
people is just it's like a hard cuz we
do have like a stage Persona we have all
these things it's like it is just a
weird [__] it's like bye I'm like about
to go on the road for [__] and also
we get like a type of attention that's
like we don't you know I had one
boyfriend that was so like thirsty for
my attention I was like I don't know how
to explain to you that like every night
an audience of strangers gives me what
you think that I should be seeking from
you
and it's so much better wait Julian I
have a question for you um in a gay
relationship let's say mm or FF who do
you guys talk about who pays for the
date or like what is the dynamic when it
comes to money how cute do you look look
at this oh
god um it's so funny because I get asked
that question all the time I think it
depends on Vibe really right like it it
depends on what the interaction Steph
and I
are I've never not been like they bring
waiters bring me the check like give me
an example of a dynamic that where
you've either felt like oh I think I'm
taking care of this bill and when you've
felt like no he should take care of this
uh I mean see I'm the type of person
that normally just wants to take care of
the bill no matter what so like I feel
like I'm always in that position even
with like friends I'll always mov hell
yeah you know what I mean got this I
just always cuz then I I don't want to
easy yeah it's easy but I think like
with dates I think like one time I
remember it was like this daddy
um it was fantastic which is a very
opposite role of what I like normally am
um but he it was like it was clear right
like you didn't you didn't have to ask
you knew that he was going to get his
card out do you know what I mean like I
love that yeah which was fantastic and I
didn't even have to like I didn't even
go to my wallet I literally just like
the bill came and he like immediately
grabbed it and I was like this is how
about isn't it weird stuff when you're
like on the road with a when you're
opening for a comic and then you got out
to dinner with them and then you're like
I mean obviously they're going to pay I
guess but it's like do you have ever
have that like I used to open for Jim
Norton and we would go to these like
expensive dinners I mean I was like
broke of [__] and the bill would come
and I'm not [__] this person I'm not
dating them but I'm like do I have to
just going can I just get you like
McDonald's one day like to yeah it's
like there's always like that awkward
like power thing even if there's not sex
involved with it I feel like but I yeah
waitress that's basically how you know
that I I'm only catching friend Vibes is
if we go out on a date and I pay oh
really then it's like if it's yeah
especially if it's a all the girl dates
I've been on I've paid and I haven't
walked away feeling good about it I
don't like feeling like the being hot
girl is annoying yeah I'm not gay and
it's like when [__] try to pull that
[__] on me where they treat you like I'm
gonna I'm not giving you special
treatment because you're a hot girl yeah
I'm not trying to [__] you so because
it's it's it it does go back to like
gender Norms right like even with men
with gay men it's like if I'm going out
with like it sounds really awful but if
I'm going out with like a more
flamboyant guy for example like I'm
going to expect to pay right if I'm
going out with that Daddy you know Burly
guy to me it it's him paying right like
yeah it's not great but it's just I just
also like who makes the most money you
know but we don't know that up
front know the first date they pay I
always know same same I like the first
date they pay a nice classic here's
where I felt like I needed to pay I was
a lot taller than her and I know that's
some weird [__] up thing but I'm like
no I feel like I should yeah and she was
like softer and she was in a dress and I
was a little bit more you know what I
mean like and so I was like I think I'm
paying because I think I'm the [__]
dude here and it's so like that's such a
old way of thinking I should I would if
I like being wi and D I should that
should apply to both men and women right
yeah there should never be splitting
ever it's like you get one I get one at
least I had a split I had a bad never
split we're not doing math we're not
doing splits it's so annoying two cards
I was broke at when I first moved to LA
you go out with friends and everyone is
splitting itemizing that's why that's
writing on the back of the track no I
went to what's the place in um K town
called it's like the old ship it's like
a boat place oh my God blank on the name
it's a it's a really good bar for like a
like a date bar I go with this guy he
talks about how he owns two houses the
whole [__] time over happy hour Bill
comes it's I swear to God $32 he goes oh
would have split it the bartender goes
you're gonna split the bill and I was
like this like old Korean woman was like
you're splitting it and I was like we're
splitting it and I slid my car it was
[__] embarrassing it was like $16
what the [__] it was I was like I and
then he went give me hug and I was like
nah I'm not in the mood for that right
now like it was so you just bragged
about owning two homes and you can't buy
me it was the drinks were $4 like it was
crazy yeah even in my like my merch
lines like I'm always like to the I'm
like buy her the shirt like what are you
doing yeah like do not let make her pull
her card out [__] buy her the [__]
shirt buy her the goddamn shirt
especially if it's a cheap bill whatever
I'm over it 32 bucks it was crazy it was
insane you're not it was fun the first
like when I I feel like I've only gone
on like actually like four dates
probably in my life because of just my
the culture of drinking and my my
history was just well yeah I mean [__]
people and you're dating them and no I
can relate to that or whatever but
actual like dates cuz I never really
used the apps I only use the apps like
once once or twice well I can relate to
that which is why dating now I'm like
I'm forcing myself to go on them but
they're [__] miserable it feels like
a [__] shitty job not know that
there's like a Vibe and a phone match
ahead of time is that's hard yeah
terrible it's like probably I'd liken it
to like performing in like a super cold
room like the crowd is just there with
their [__] arms crossed and now
you're just trying to like try to create
some type of [__] energy now would be
like if I was single now I would be good
at it because I think I have the courage
to reject people now like before I
really didn't like have the balls to
reject people I would literally just
[__] people just like I I would hate
them from the second they sat down and
be like the only way I know how to get
out of this is to have sex with you but
now I think I could be like hey I'm just
not feeling the vibe like have a good
night I do that I start like sober and
then by my fifth rank I'm like ah damn
I'm gonna [__] I drank I feel like I
would like drink myself into like just
cuz I was like oh I don't want for no
godamn but I never it's because I never
practiced going out on dates when I was
younger because if I like the boy I'd be
like my friends and I are going to this
thing come join it was always a group
thing only because like I hated I can't
sustain eye contact for very long and
just being in front of some a stranger
is is straight up like the worst thing I
can do to like my census I think you
should go to this bar in um Toronto it's
all it's pitch black and the bar fenders
are all blind that'd be perfect for
that's perfect for me you literally
should go there that's literally the
ideal you can't see them yeah you're
having a chat in the dark there's no
alcohol in the drink they pour next to
it oh lot of broken glass you're not
getting what you ordered I'll tell you
that you're not getting what you ordered
blood everywhere bloodier than Herman I
I I was on the road and this guy wanted
to go on a date with me and I brought
Pavone I brought my buddy with me I was
like yeah my buddy's coming with me he's
like what I was like yeah and then he
ended up got a meal and he paid for the
whole thing he paid for his food drinks
and I was like and then at the end of
the night he like made a comment how he
wants to do comedy he yeah I'm going to
mik wait I no [__] oh no you can't
you're not allowed to want to do comedy
and I like oh done and then he's like oh
should I walk you guys back should I
come back to your room and ph's like
buddy you're out hit the curb hit the
bricks you ain't getting [__] you you
you said the wrong thing and I went to
the bathroom he's like so how's it going
with me and staff he's like I'm not kid
man she's not going to [__] you you want
to be a comedian you got to go home like
it was it was the best I want to bring a
buddy on every day to go on now that is
so fun it was so funny yeah I um yeah
there was a comic I like kind of dated a
little bit on enough but um do we know
who it is we yeah I can tell you later
but so I um we were like vibing I just
gone through a breakup and it was like
an immediate I remember Esther being
there and being like
woo like it was just a weird like all of
a sudden like Bing binging and I was
supposed to go um out to eat with my
friend Tate who's like this big Tate
Fletcher he's like this big buff like
he's like in every he's in the
background of every movie where there's
like a gang with guns and who was like
in Breaking Bad and stuff but um so we
were supposed to go out to dinner he's
been my friend since I lived in Santa Fe
and wait you from Santa Fe I'm kidding
what's that you say from Santa
Fe but I'm not from there I'm from
Philly yeah but you were live in
San oh excuse me my phone's R you're
from Canada sorry I can't turn off oh
it's who was it guy it's a guy that it's
very complicated it's a it's a different
guy who may or may not work at The
Comedy Store who I have a thing for and
it's been a very long dragged out
situation noted I'll tell you mine and
later okay but so okay so that night
we're like vibing and it is kind of like
oh [__] like I really would like to be
hanging out with him I know I want to
hang out with my friend Tate but it's
like this would be fun the guy somehow
invites himself on the head the friend
date the guy invit I don't know how it
happened but he he comes with so it's
the three of
us and we're obviously learning right
and Tate and I are not on a romantic
date or anything but it's like it's just
like such a weird thing that happens and
in the end I should never have hooked up
with this guy he let tapate pay for the
whole thing he let T pay for the whole
how embarrassing that's embarrassing and
then I did I still I hooked up with them
there's so many for a while I have a
question so I have a crush on a comedian
Big Crush this just happened I don't
know if you I'll say the name after he
did my podcast you know when you meet
somebody okay is it thing where you meet
somebody and right away you're like oh
my God Like We Vibe in a way like rii
like we're both like cry laughing I'm
like this is the man we met we met in
Pittsburgh then he did my podcast we
were like laughing so hard and I was
like just F I'm like [__] it so we're
talking about dating he sang on I was
like well would you ever date a comedian
he's like no like the hardest know and I
was like and even my producer saw he's
like your soul sucked out of your eyes
all a sudden went oh what about an
actress I was like trying but I was like
but then we've been texting non-stop he
wants to hang out and I'm like I'm so
crazy that I'm like I know in my head he
just wants like friend but in my sick
head I'm like I'll turn him I'll show
I'll show him the old toll of charm I'll
give him a real good [__] he'll
change his mind I'm like I need to stop
because this guy want me he's like I'm
never dating comedian I'm like I'll
change you like I'm like so crazy I'm
like I need to stop I'm like it's just
sometimes you meet that person you're
like how does he not feel this yeah and
I'm like like there's no way yeah
there's no way there's no way I'm like I
know and then my told my friend JZ and
she's like oh he dated somebody one of
my friends she's like a Barbie though I
was like well I'm like a Bulgarian
Barbie we're built differently
lot of hair a lot of [__] nose but
I'm like I just feel like I don't know
in my head I'm like like when you meet a
guy like that immediately I'm like
wouldn't you want to do this all the
time and I know guys are just like
that's a that's a good friend of mine
but I'm like why wouldn't you want to
joke around [__] time [__] like it's
so annoying it's so annoying I know you
want some dumb [__] that's just going
to [__] the whole time like what are
we doing here I remember okay so the guy
that I that got Tate to pay for the meal
he we were like in this like flirtatious
stage poor and we went to do a show but
Tate wasn't trying to date me no but
poor Tate for having to [__] you know
he's been friends with me so long he's
[__] dealt with this [__] he's
knows what it's like to hang out with me
he knows there's going to be some other
thing happening or whatever but so and
also by the way he used to I used to be
his waitress and he was like it was like
their little [__] sober crew would
come in I'd get no sales no tip I would
just have to they're so high maintenance
of [__] this is what he gets and um
what does that mean Step Closer oh CL
sorry you're like you suck the dick suck
it harder hit the uula
um but so we went to a show together
because you know like when you do start
dating a comic you you just start
getting booked on the same shows as them
it's like that like that so we're
hanging out and he was flirting with
these two other girls in front of me at
a comedy show and I just came up and I
said like the funniest like I just I
can't remember exactly it was but I
whispered something in his ear and he I
got laugh so and I just was like they'll
never do that no they'll never like I
just I was like I know I'm the funniest
person on earth like right now I know I
just said to you the funniest thing you
could ever hear but I I think that but
that was another red flag like why are
you flirting with your girls in front of
me always was doing loved how anxiously
attached I was but I I don't know I
maybe it's that like us women we find
funny people so attractive I don't know
if that's the other way
around
find funny girls like I don't know if
that's even part of their I bet you it's
at the bottom of the list we would be on
the top of the world we'd be on the top
of the world of thousand I'd be married
with 19 children yeah it's like we'd be
everything yeah I'd have a hot hosit of
my ex-boyfriend being a psycho blob um
yeah no I literally like yeah I it's I
don't think it is out there because I
just left being like I cuz I love
[__] and then immediately riffing in
bed that's my favorite thing coming
laughing like that the good guys love it
the good guys the they're they have
intact egos it's like their ego can't
handle us being funny the guys with good
egos that are like like Todd's always
like I did so many mushrooms in high
school I had like so many ego deaths so
young he doesn't like I could say
anything to him it doesn't matter but
it's like I had to like I I mean I went
through hell before I met him I mean
hell because they don't they like it's
like the funnier you are the more
they're like disgusted about I I'm like
sorry I'm making you laugh so hard
that's why good like I was like we're on
the same page I'm like I would dat a
comedian everyone's always like you
really I'm like you know you're you're
both on the road you know you schedules
perfectly it's there's a lot of benefits
a lot of benefits yeah there's benit
funny but I feel like for a lot of girls
like nightmare my God it's a requirement
for a guy to be funny at least for like
us right but for them it's not a
requirement it's just a bonus it's just
something that's like oh great like
she's that too she's all of these things
that I require but she's also you think
guys like kalila asked us earlier she's
like can you date a guy if he's not
funny I was like absolutely not but do
you think there's like a male podcast
somewhere they're like could you date a
girl if she was funny and they're like
absolutely
not hell no but some guys like it I
think the guys like we're talking about
like dumb where he's like it's guys that
like like a woman who because it's like
kind of masculine to be funny I guess in
their heads or something I don't know or
like command a room or like yeah I don't
know [__] off it's annoying what a shame
it is it's like but it's just certain
it's yeah it's a shame got boy choc fers
shame I know they there are I mean I
[__] I [__] a couple fans now I had
a guy quote one of my jokes while he was
inside me I like that no he this mama
likee and I'm like you need to stop
right now like and then did my voice too
and I was like it was not a turn on it
was so disgusting go go way deeper of
course no it was would you date a guy
with a very soft high pitched
voice
um yeah if he was funny a big HW no h h
i have dated the most hideous disgusting
monsters because they're funny like I
have dated like horrible people because
they make me laugh yeah see bad humans
bad humans but the thing is those guys
once they're mean enough they stop being
funny do you know what I mean yeah yeah
yeah I think also if you get like my ex
was so unfunny and like now looking back
I thought he was I'm like ew yeah like I
was
so yeah I was like what the hell is
wrong with me that's the best feeling in
the world when you wake up one morning
and you're like I am so over this
[__] oh yeah cuz you know you've
just like you go through the grieving
process and everything hurts and they're
still a part of you that wants them back
that feeling that first day where you're
like oh I got through that I am done
it's such a [__] I just want to like I
saw I was celebrate and drink and get I
was at the comedy store last night and I
was talking to Blair SOI and she was
like she was like
um my ex-boyfriend was there and she was
like is it weird to see him and I was
like it is so weird like it's not like
it's not even like shade to him it's
like I cannot believe who I was when I
did it like when I see him I'm like wow
yeah yeah yeah like it is not there
anymore like at all like there is like
nothing I can't believe it that's how
there's some yeah there's some like that
my ex I literally it was like the next
day I was like I'll never ever and I
haven't had one thought I was like I was
like no I also found out horrendous
stuff about them so I was like oh I'm
like now physically and mentally if you
don't dislike them cuz one of my best
friends one of my best best friends was
someone that I dated 15 years ago and
he's married now he has kids like I'm
close to his wife um I I don't even want
to think that we ever even like so much
as kissed or even flirted it makes me
[__] Weir it feels like it feels
weird it feels weird it feels disgusting
to me like it if him and I like we would
never Broach that topic like in a
million years it's so dead and done and
it makes me feel like so ick out of my
mind I never am like oh I remin this
fondly no no no so you don't even have
to hate them they could just be someone
you still like love in a different way
but you're like never the [__] again no
I'll tell you what he did off air and
guess what you're going to hate him
you're going to hate him bad tell me
tell me oh off air yeah I'll tell you
off air you hate him everyone who met
him was like I was so creeped out by I
was like happy for you cuz you were
really happy but I was like he was like
a little weird a little
yeah wrapping it up wrapping it
up no but yeah it's weird it's like sh
acces but you're just like who was I
that I like yeah there's some there's
some that I have like fond memories of
like that was a time in my life and that
makes sense but there's others where I'm
like the [__] was I thinking what was I
was I was like mentally unwell I was
just not in tune with myself and I just
yeah yeah not that you don't like I'm
like oh I like parts of this person and
they're funny and they're smart and
stuff but I'm like I like lived I like
cooked for you no I know right you're
like I cried for you I [__] did
everything for you yeah it's such an
insane thought for me to be like wow I
devoted my entire being to you yeah and
I let them treat me in a way I would
never let anyone treat me now like way
I'm now would
never is it so empowering to be like we
it shows how much you're like growing
and being like no but it's like you
can't believe how much you grow you're
like oh my God it it feels good to look
back and be like yeah it's like
impressive that we can be like that's it
we're done with that we've moved on we
have to wrap this up I need to we need
to talk names we got to go Nam yeah we
have some names Steph thank you so much
for doing thank you for having me this
is fun i' had so much fun we had a good
week we had a good week watch our
episode of Steph infection too I'm GNA
have you on annwood as well big fan
Steph's hilarious you had me spitting a
little bit here good what's your
Instagram St step Tov follow me on that
that's that's it if you want to watch me
do stupid [__] yeah and look you
actually high quality funny [__] hot
young polite and decent boy slug that
can handle a beautiful strong woman like
Steph hit us up maybe that'd be nice
just let us be funny what's wrong with
you idiots they would be watching too
hit her up we'll see you guys next week
and clean the smegma out of your please
please before you send the pick thank
you bye
[Music]
guys
oh